-When Donald Trump lost
by 7 million votes in 2020,
many assumed
the Republican Party
would quickly jettison him,
but the opposite has happened.
The GOP is refusing
to move on from Trump.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
When Trump lost,
there was a hope
we could all move on
and talk about something else.
In a perfect world,
right now I'd be hosting a show
called "Major Crimes,"
which would be a round-up
of who Joe Biden's German
shepherd had attacked that week.
I'd host in a trench coat
like Robert Stack in
"Unsolved Mysteries."
"While it's always been known
for back-stabbing
and dirty dealings,
this week, Washington, D.C.,
went to the dogs."
That would have been the show.
But, of course,
it did not work out like that.
In fact, as we pointed out
many times before the election,
that was never gonna happen.
Trump didn't
come out of nowhere,
and the toxic political culture
he exposed
wasn't simply gonna vanish.
Even after he left office,
the conditions that created him
and the destruction he left
behind would inevitably remain.
We always knew that
would be the case.
We just didn't know Republicans
themselves would be so eager
to cling to the abject failure
that was the Trump era.
They're like a bunch
of burnt-out uncles
reliving their high school
football glory days.
But they weren't
the star quarterback.
They were the backup punter
and they lost the state
championship by 7 million votes.
Now, it's worth noting that's
not how they've always felt,
especially during Trump's
second impeachment.
Trump incited a violent mob
of insurrectionists,
a mob that ransacked
the Capitol,
attacked police officers,
and threatened to
kill the Vice President
in order to disrupt the lawful
counting of electoral votes.
And when it came time to
hold him accountable for that,
Republicans told us
to just let it go
since Trump was on his way out
anyway.
-I'm ready to move on.
I'm ready to end
the impeachment trial
because I think it's
blatantly unconstitutional.
I'm ready to get on with trying
to solve the nation's problems.
-I think the country
needs to move forward.
We've got a lot of issues
that we need to be working on.
-They hate Donald J. Trump,
and they're engaging in an act
that I think is petty.
I think it is retribution.
I think it is vindictive.
And I think it's
a waste of time.
And so, to coin a phrase,
I think it's time to move on.
-I'm sure Ted Cruz has heard
that phrase a lot in his life.
"Ted, this relationship
isn't working.
It's time to move on."
"Ted, the beard,
it's not a thing.
It's time to move on."
"Ted, Carly is not coming back.
-The next President of the
United States -- Ted Cruz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Remember that,
when Ted Cruz chose
a running mate
and then she, I guess,
fell down an open manhole
and disappeared forever?
She probably staged that
just to get away from Ted Cruz.
"Don't worry, Carly,
I'll come and get you."
"That's okay. I actually
like it down here with
the sewer people."
"This is a sewer?
I thought it was the F train.
Oh, Rudy! Ya dope!"
These guys backed
nearly everything Trump did
for four years.
Then the second he incited
a violent insurrection,
they told us all to move on.
Like, Marco Rubio had an
especially cynical explanation
for why he thought the media
and the left were so obsessed
with impeaching Trump
for the crime of trying
to violently overthrow democracy
instead of just letting him
off the hook.
-This is not the right use
of Congress' time.
It's vindictive.
This is all about
the left's demand for revenge.
And I'm gonna be frank,
some of the people out there
in the political entertainment
business,
this is about ratings
and about clicks
because this is another drama
story that adds to the show.
-The only reason Donald Trump
was good for ratings
is he was bad for
everything else.
He was good for ratings
in the same way
that hurricanes are great
for The Weather Channel.
"Honey, it's channel 4-1-7."
His presidency was
a once-in-a-century catastrophe
filled with corruption, chaos,
misery, and suffering.
Of course people
wanted to stay informed.
That's like saying
a zombie apocalypse
would be good
for ham radio sales.
"Hello? Hello, we are
seven survivors in Denver.
Where are you? Brains?
Where is that? Wisconsin?
Load up the van. We're going to
Brains, Wisconsin."
But that was then.
Same Republicans who told us
to move on from Trump
after he incited
a violent insurrection
are now clinging to Trump
like doomsday preppers
clinging to a plastic bag
filled with gas.
And side note, guys. Let's, you
know, just stop hoarding gas.
This isn't "Mad Max."
He's President Joe,
not Immortan Joe.
What's next, Sean Hannity
hosting a show
as The Doof Warrior?
"Did I say it right?"
We'll find out
in next week's corrections.
NBC is putting us on prime time
and rebranding it
as "Chicago Corrections."
"Bad news, boss,
you got another flub."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is Republicans
have made it very clear
that Donald Trump
is the leader of their party now
and for the foreseeable future,
and they're refusing to move on
from the disastrous Trump years.
-We are a pro-America
populist party
rooted in
conservative principle
with Donald Trump as our leader.
-To try to erase Donald Trump
from the Republican Party
is insane.
And the people
who try to erase him
are going to wind up
getting erased.
It's impossible for this party
to move forward
without President Trump
being its leader.
-They look at Donald J. Trump,
and they look at the millions
and millions of people inspired,
who went to battle, fighting
alongside President Trump,
and they're terrified.
And they want him to go away.
Let me tell you this right now.
Donald J. Trump
ain't going anywhere.
-First of all,
there's nothing more grading
than Ted Cruz trying
to fire up a crowd.
He might actually have
negative charisma.
He sounds the way
hot dog water smells.
He's the guy casinos bring in
when there's a hot roller
at the craps table.
"Come on, lucky seven.
Oh, no. Snake eyes.
Too bad. So sad."
I think Cruz is right that
Trump isn't going anywhere
but only in the literal sense,
that he physically
does not go anywhere.
He never leaves Mar-a-Lago.
The most exercise he gets
is kicking his ball
back onto the fairway
and wandering from room to room,
interrupting various
private events
like a guy on a business trip
at a Radisson
looking for
the right conference room.
"Is this
the voter fraud meeting?"
"No, it's a wedding reception."
"Would you like me to say
a few words about voter fraud?"
Trump's like an improviser
who has an audience plant
yell out suggestions.
"Can I get a location?"
"Wedding."
"Can I get a topic?"
"Voter fraud."
"We take you there now."
In fact, Republicans are
so deeply attached to Trump,
despite how horrendous he was
for the country,
they can't seem to stop
talking about him,
as Fox News pointed out
during an interview
with Mitch McConnell this week.
-Since April 24th, fundraising
e-mails from Republicans
have mentioned
the former President 97 times,
an average of more than
five times a day.
You're saying the focus
is not on the past,
but you're using
the former President's name,
and Republicans are,
to raise money for 2022.
-Five times a day.
Republicans talk about Trump
more than I talk about
my Vince Vaughn impression.
"Geez, man, give it a rest."
Ooh, I did a switcheroo.
In fact, one of the those
Republicans is Marco Rubio,
the same guy who claimed
it was the left
who is obsessed with Trump
for ratings and clicks.
Rubio sent out a fundraising
e-mail this week
bragging about the fact that
he was one of the first people
mentioned by name
on Trump's new blog.
Rubio wrote
in a fundraising e-mail,
"I was lucky enough to be
one of his first posts."
It should be noted that
this is the same blog
that the former President used
to call Kentucky Derby winner
Medina Spirit a junky.
And I know there are some
out there
who think we should ignore
when a former President
calls a horse a junky.
Well, I just want to say,
no can do.
I don't have the strength
to ignore it
when a grown man hears a horse
failed a drug test
and then calls the horse
a junky.
Not now, not ever.
Wish I could.
But I can't.
Also, can it get more pathetic
than Rubio saying
"I was lucky enough to be
one of his first posts"?
Republicans talk about Trump
the way teens at a concert
talk about One Direction.
"Jenna, oh, my God,
he looked at me.
Harry looked at me. He made
direct eye contact with me.
Jenna, did you see that?
Jenna, did you see him
look right at my direct eyes?
Jenna, are you listening?
Harry Styles looked at me,
Jenna,
and now we're gonna get married.
And, Jenna, you're not coming,
Jenna.
You're not coming
because you didn't believe me.
You didn't believe me, Jenna."
"Oh, wait. Oh, hold on.
No, he's looking at you, Jenna."
Republicans are obsessed
with Trump
because they have
no central ideology
other than their hostility
toward democracy.
The big lie that
the election was stolen
is their only core belief.
And I'm guessing a lot of them
don't even believe it.
They just know that Trump does.
When I was in college and a girl
wanted to read my tarot cards,
I definitely acted like
I was interested
in what the page of cups meant.
But Republicans know they can
weaponize Trump's big lie
to make it harder
for people to vote
and, thus, easier for the GOP
to win elections.
That's why their number-one
legislative priority
is codifying Trump's big lie
through voter suppression laws
so they can rig the game
in their own favor.
They've calculated that
they don't need to appeal
to a majority of Americans
the way a healthy democracy
normally works
if they can just exploit
antidemocratic methods
like gerrymandering
and electoral college
to stay in power,
which is why they've decided
to stay so closely tied
to Trump.
In a way, you can see
how the incentives work.
It's like, in a normal world,
the Jets have to get better
in order to win games,
but if they can pass legislation
only making it legal
for opposing teams to score on
Tuesdays from 9:00 A.M. to noon,
they'd be in way better shape.
"Touchdown -- Chiefs. And that's
not good for the Jets.
Wait. Hold on.
The ref is running over,
and Patrick Mahomes' signature
is not an exact match.
They're taking the points
off the board."
The point is,
Republicans have calculated
they don't need democracy,
so they can stick by
a deeply unpopular ex-President
who never once
cracked 50% job approval
and never won the popular vote.
In fact, they're so openly
hostile to democracy,
they're actually
excusing the mob
that seized the Capitol
on January 6th,
as we saw yesterday when
GOP Congressman Andrew Clyde
said the insurrection looked
more like a group of tourists.
-There was no insurrection.
And to call it an insurrection,
in my opinion,
is a bold-faced lie.
Watching the TV footage of those
who entered the Capitol
and walked through Statuary Hall
showed people
in an orderly fashion
staying between
the stanchions and ropes
taking videos and pictures.
You know, if you didn't know
the TV footage
was a video
from January the 6th,
you would actually think
it was a normal tourist visit.
-The only way that makes sense
is if this guy is French.
"It looks like a normal
American tourist to me,
yes, slobs,
always with the McDonald's,
Mickey Mouse ears, trying to
kill the Vice President."
Seriously, are you out
of your [bleep] mind?
Why am I asking that question?
Of course you're out
of your [bleep] mind.
They stormed barricades
and offices,
attacked police officers,
and threatened to kill
the Vice President.
No sane person saw that footage
and thought,
"Huh, how peaceful.
Is that a school field trip?
Did they make lanyards
and use the buddy system?"
This is how deranged
the modern GOP is.
In a healthy-functioning
democracy,
a deeply unpopular President
who lost badly
after leaving the country
in ruins
would be quickly jettisoned
by his party,
but Republicans are sticking
with Trump
because they've calculated
they don't need to appeal
to a majority of Americans.
They figure, no matter
how many times they lose,
if they can rig the game
in their favor,
the Republican Party...
-Ain't going anywhere.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 millions meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated. We love you.